1953 in Hungary is communist and a
puppet state of the USSR along with all
of these nations Eastern Europe had been
like this since the end of the Second
World War but 1953 was an important year
since this or Joseph Stalin died with
Stalin's iron-fisted rule now over there
was an opportunity to change tack for
communist states like Hungary Hungary
was taught by Moscow to replace its
current Prime Minister Mukhtar Akashi
with someone a bit less Stalin II a man
called imre nagy a previously purged
critic of Stalinism was selected to take
over and begin reforms to make hungary
you know less stalin ii Rakata had been
a harsh ruler and was responsible for
over 100,000 people being imprisoned of
many hundreds being shocked the most
important of these victims was a man
called laszlo roy who had purchased a
fair few people himself not attempted to
make some economic reforms but record
she managed to convince the USSR's new
leader Nikita Khrushchev that Nagy
wasn't reliable and so Nagy was removed
in 1955 rákóczi was now back in charge
but he was deeply unpopular with the
people of Hungary mostly because of the
whole purging thing he was also a
staunch opponent of Yugoslavia and its
leader Yas it brought Tito Yugoslavia
had broken off relations with the USSR
in 1948 and left common form an
international network of communist
nations and Khrushchev was looking to
bring Yugoslavia back into the fold
thus having a man in charge of Hungary
who shot people for being Tito lists
wasn't a good look for them in mid 1956
rákóczi was removed from office by the
Soviets and replaced by air Nakuru who
was also a fierce Stalinist who hated
any idea of reform for Gura ties with
Yugoslavia with the least of his
problems since students across the
country began to form independent groups
looking for change on the 23rd of
October a major protest broke out in
Budapest whose organisers made several
demands they wanted economic and
democratic reforms the return of Narges
prime minister and for soviet troops to
leave the country
Garou a band this demonstration but was
worried about looking weak and so he
allowed the protest to go ahead until
they said thinks he didn't like it and
so he bound them again and when they
didn't the first Soviet soldiers
fighting with the crowds to stop the
protests in the tracks the Hungarian
Communist Party opted to bring back Nagy
to show that they were listening he's
important to remember that the
Hungarians couldn't act quickly since
they need a permission from Moscow
before taking any sort of drastic action
discussions between Hungary in the USSR
on what to do were carried out by janosh
Kedar and the Hungarian side and Anastas
Mikoyan on behalf of the Soviets
Kedar urged restraint at first since he
felt that not all of those protesting
was simply trying to overthrow the
government
in the end Moscow
agree to negotiate with the protesters
in the hopes of ending the protest Nagy
promised to dissolve the secret police
and the Soviet troops would leave the
capital this did sweet nothing is so
Nagy desperately promised to end
one-party rule sort of and to restore
Hungarian democracy sort of Nagy was
still a communist through and through
though he simply felt that a less
centralized in free a form of communism
was a better option he also promised
Hungarian independence by demanding the
Soviet troops leave Hungary all together
and that Hungary would leave the newly
formed Warsaw Pact a defensive communist
Alliance and the ussr's answer to NATO
for the USSR the abandonment of
one-party rule was too much non November
the third he told the troops to the
Hungarian border in response Nagy
declared that Hungary was no longer a
member of the Warsaw Pact and wanted to
be considered a neutral state like
Yugoslavia negotiations between Hungary
in the USSR broke down and on November
the 4th Soviet forces crossed into
Hungary to supplement the troops already
there now urged the people of Hungary to
resist which they did taking for their
symbol the Hungarian flag but with the
communist symbol cut out Soviet troops
attacked Budapest but despite their
advantages Hungarian resistance was
extremely fierce thus advances into the
city were slowed kadar was soon
appointed as the new head of government
and urged his fellow countrymen and all
Hungarian soldiers to side with the USSR
to restore order none did most of
Budapest was captured on the 4th and the
Hungarian Revolution was over in the end
roughly two and a half thousand
Hungarians were killed in about 700
Soviet soldiers with them the vast
majority in Budapest
soon afterwards Nagy was arrested and
sent to Romania the Soviets in Kedah
restored order over the following months
and over 20,000 people were arrested in
over two hundred thousand people fled
the country strict laws were enacted
which handed out the death penalty for
anyone who called for strikes but the
aftermath didn't really see any
particularly brutal repressions Nagy was
returned to Hungary and in 1958 he was
found guilty of fomenting
counter-revolution and executed I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching a special thanks to James
Bissonnette ozark a flash Henry Robin
Winston Cawood Adam Harvey and Skye
Chapelle
you